GRACE TEO: Having our students
be prepared to face failure
is really important,
because I think
it's essential to
the design process.
Professor Rob Miller
came in to do a lecture
on user-centered
design, very early
on in the semester,
where we basically
presented them this design model
where you do iterative design.
Which means you quickly
come up with a prototype,
you fail as fast as
possible, you figure out
where everything's
going wrong, and then
you make a second prototype.
And you keep going around and
around and around this circle,
until you reach that
perfect prototype
at the end of the day.
And so I think they
knew from the start
that they were going
to have to just keep
making things and seeing how
they were going to go wrong.
So failure became very
[? intrinsic ?] part
of the design process.
In fact, we told them
right from the start,
we expect you to have
three prototypes at least
by the end of the semester.
And these are when your
prototypes should be ready by,
and these are the weeks where
you will get to test them.
And every week they had to
come back and tell the mentors
where things went well, and
where things didn't go well,
according to some set
of success metrics.
WILLIAM LI: Yeah,
I think the design
review of these mid-term
panels were really just that.
To try to get feedback
on the design,
or really explain the progress
that they had made so far,
and so I think that was a
big reason why we did that.
I think having mentors this
year was helpful on this front
as well.
The mentors were pretty
in touch with how
teams were progressing.
We had each team fill out
this little form every week
explaining what was going well
and what they needed help with.
So a big part of it was
creating the culture
that it doesn't have to go
perfectly well every week.
There can be setbacks, there
can be different challenges
or obstacles to overcome.
But we're here to
work through them
and figure out how to
deal with this situation,
or brainstorm some ideas.
One of the other
things that we tried
this year was to
have these lightning
updates at the end
of every week's lab,
just to inform the rest
of class where you're at,
and what you were trying,
what progress you were making.
I think this maybe
set up a little bit
of friendly competition, to see
where other projects are at.
But it also helped
maybe the class
feel like we're all in
this together, I suppose.
It's not always
going to be easy.
Maybe there's
logistics challenges.
Maybe there's design challenges.
Maybe there's other
sorts of things.
So I think students were
pretty open to sharing honestly
what their progress was,
and what they were doing.
At least that's
what we tried to do.
GRACE TEO: We did get feedback
from students, though,
that the lightning updates
might have been too regular.
And they did say that it would
have been nice to have it once
every two weeks
instead of every week,
and that would just
give them more time
to work together as a team.
And we realized too
that, for our students,
being able to do group
work outside of class
is actually difficult
because they all
have such busy schedules.
So any time they structured
a time within a class
to just do group work together,
that was really valuable
for them.